a woman is running the vatican's museum
for the first time in its history the
Vatican holds hundreds of thousands of
pieces of art in its collection Barbour
Yatta
is one of the first female directors of
major museums like the Metropolitan
Museum of Art the Louvre and the British
Museum
she took Seth Doane on a special tour of
the museum's where she takes the
attention off herself to focus on the
art Seth good morning good morning
Barbara otto was not expecting to be
promoted to director but says it's a
privilege to oversee a collection here
the Vatican Museums which will take your
breath away the Vatican Museums are so
packed with treasures it can be hard to
know where to look there's one Pope's
gallery of maps Raphael's
Transfiguration the roughly 2,000 year
old Laconte the first object in museum
when it was conceived in the early 1500s
or this Augusto de primaporta this
culture in all our schools and in really
is the icon of Roman time she has a
degree in our history and studied this
famed Statue of Emperor Augustus now as
director Barbara gossip is in charge of
it some of the greatest artwork in the
world is in your care yes I feel I feel
the weight of that the weight of that
responsibility in its collection the
Vatican holds a mind-boggling two
hundred thousand pieces of art only
about 10% are on display but finding a
stunning place to sit and chat is no
problem what a room in which to do an
interview it's a special place he's
really something that feels you
privileged yatta a 20 year veteran of
the Vatican says she was surprised when
Pope Francis announced in December that
she'd become the museum's director this
mother of three was also surprised by
all of the attention paid to her gender
I make a joke of that because everybody
keep asking me how do you feel how do
you feel that to be the woman I feel as
a person really the Vatican is a
famously male
dominated institution you know I worked
in the Vatican Library for 20 years and
after eight years I became head of a
department I never felt discriminated to
be a woman in the Vatican Library she
shrugs off any special attention she's
got work to do in the last two months of
2017 we had 70,000 people more than last
year
the museum attracts more than 6 million
visitors a year for going against the
flow that's it
but it's a balance trying to attract
more visitors while not diluting the
experience on the day we visited she
estimated crowd size 19,000 people
20,000 people today is that typical is
that a lot is a lot for this time of the
year Yatta plans to hire more guards so
they can be open for longer hours while
the Sistine Chapel part of the museum is
often full we found plenty of space
around other masterpieces including the
Nile
Yatta is working to get guides to
encourage visitors to stop at
lesser-known spots there's also the
issue of keeping so much art on display
and in good shape it takes a team of
more than 150 people to work on constant
maintenance and restoration if you do
make an O and Bailey preservation and
conservation you really do not need much
restoration what struck us is there's so
much it fills not just public spaces but
private passageways even just in a small
side room by elevator there's
spectacular
look at that oh yeah yes near this back
elevator della robia the florentine
famous for his work with glazed
terracotta and in the director's office
there's her desk is a very nice is the 9
desk for sure he has his coat of arms so
he was part of this collection yes a
picture of her boss sits over her
shoulder
it's a reminder that this is part of a
greater mission she believes art can act
as a spiritual ambassador of course I'm
Catholic and I do believe that arts
takes you to faith
next up the Vatican Museums will have
some of its collection on display in
China
Yatta says that is an effort to build
spiritual bridges in a place where there
are significant restrictions on
traditional missionary work Nora
all right that's down there in Vatican
City oh wow Wow don't you like the
phrase art as a spiritual ambassador
yeah it takes your faith it really does
yeah it never gets old going to the
Vatican and those museums